you speak to a lot of companies and
really see businesses investing in all
sorts of companies what would you how
would you characterize the business
environment right now when it comes to
hiring when it comes to expanding adding
jobs I think there's a lot of concern
that Washington is not in sync with the
American Dream anymore from the business
point of view I'm not saying it can't be
repaired but if you think about the
pendulum how far it's swung to the left
when we actually call business leaders
that build the infrastructure of our
country fat cats that just doesn't sit
well with me and I can speak for many
many other entrepreneurs and say listen
what makes this country great is the
private sector creating private sector
jobs funding the government that
provides us all the one of the things we
have we don't vilify it we solve for it
and we try and endorse it and help more
people become entrepreneurs in this
country we have buried them in
regulation we have scared the pants off
them with all of the volatility in the
markets and now we have dysfunctional
government that's not good I make the
assumption Murray and I hope I'm wrong
that one third of what government spends
is completely wasted and I think people
intuitively feel that it's not
market-tested investing bridges to
nowhere solicitations by various
politicians for their own interests I
mean it's all unhealthy yeah and I think
we're at a place now we got to fix it
all so how do you fix it
first thing is you overhaul the tax Act
it's it's it's a messy one tax code is
complicated we've been talking about
this for a lot of years how can we
haven't done it well I think because
we've done gone in new agenda items for
example Obamacare was clearly something
that the Democrats wanted done during
their tenure in this but you know this
last session we didn't care about
taxation yet if you want to create more
jobs in this country the number-one
thing to do would have not have been to
focus on health care would have been to
focus on job creation which meant lower
taxation and simplifying the tax code
and focusing on making the path easier
for entrepreneurs I meet them every day
and they want to be successful and the
government seems to be in their way now
not on the sidelines cheering them on
anymore